(upbeat instrumental music)
- Welcome to A Conversation
With History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Dudley Herschbach
who is the Frank B. Baird,
Jr. Professor of Science
at Harvard University and
co-recipient of the Nobel Prize
in chemistry for 1986.
He is the 2005 Hitchcock Professor
on the Berkeley campus.
Professor Herschbach, welcome to Berkeley.
- Very glad to be here.
- Welcome back to Berkeley I should say.
Where were you born and raised?
- San Jose, a third
generation native of San Jose.
- Uh-huh, California, and looking back
how do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world.
- Well, of course, they had a huge impact.
In particular I well remember
since I was the first of our family
to go to college, in fact we knew no one
who had gone to college,
that they were dubious,
they were wary, they
warned me that they'd heard
there are a lot of egghead professors
who had funny ideas and
certainly impractical ideas.
It wasn't clear that there'd
be anything worthwhile
that I would learn there, but was a danger
I might be too arrogant afterwards,
should work with my hands
and I was sort of on my guard then
when I arrived at Stanford,
where I was lucky enough
to go as an undergraduate.
- And your parents had a farm
and so your early life was
a farming life in San Jose?
- Well, near San Jose--
- [Harry] Near San Jose, okay.
- Out toward Campbell, Saratoga area.
I went to a grammar school with 80 kids
and four rooms, two grades per room,
graduating class of 11,
gives you an idea what it was like then
and the high school was about 250 people,
that was kids in Campbell.
But yeah, we had several acres.
We had potatoes, we had cows
that I milked everyday for some years.
In the summer I picked prunes
and cut cots, later walnuts.
I remember how the kids who
did that in the late season
picking walnuts, your hands
would be stained yellow
and it wouldn't go away for a few weeks
and there was sort of a
stigma attached to that.
For me didn't bother me, it
was kind of badge of honesty.
- And looking back, what did you learn
from that farming life that
affected you later in life?
Did it make you a better
scientist or what?
- It might have because I
worked a lot with my dad
who was a builder, he
built houses one at a time.
He drew the plans, he
studied to be an architect
in Oakland school, not a college,
but a special school of course.
He came out in the
depths of the depression
just when I was born, 1932,
no future for architects,
so he went into building,
which he knew something about
'cause his dad had been a builder.
But his company failed in the depression,
had to take second mortgages
and too many of them failed,
so then after that he just
built houses one at a time
and his three sons would work with him
and I heard my dad talking a lot about
this is the way a good
mechanic would do it,
by that he meant a proud craftsman
who wasn't gonna cut any corners,
but put extra bracing even
where it wouldn't be seen
and all the rest, so that certainly
I think was a powerful influence.
In fact, my dad had a favorite saying
that been the motto of my research group:
"The difficult we do immediately,
the impossible takes a little longer."
I think the second phrase
appealed a lot to a kid
as kind of a heroic thing.
My mother had nothing beyond
high school education,
but she was very interested in culture
and music and reading and all,
had a great influence on all her kids.
- Did you have any teachers
say as a high school student
that pointed you in the
direction of science
and then of course at Stanford
you must have had many
who influenced you to turn to science?
- That's right, I had a high
school chemistry teacher,
John Miseka, in fact a
master's degree from Berkeley,
it was terrific, wonderful teacher,
and he absolutely knew his stuff.
When I took freshman
chemistry later at Stanford
I discovered how good Miseka's
high school course was
and other classes at this
Campbell High School then.
I learned a lot
even though the teachers weren't
particularly well prepared.
For instance, the very first
class I had was in algebra.
The instructor walks in
and he says I don't
know much about algebra,
but I know one thing,
I've just come from
serving in artillery corps
in Second World War
and if we calculated
something the right way
but got the wrong answer,
shelled our own troops, we got no credit,
so you'll get no credit.
(laughing)
You have the right method,
but the wrong answer.
Well, within a few weeks there
are several kids in the class
who had a better grip
on algebra than he did,
but that was no sweat for him.
He regarded his job as
a former military man
as to make sure that the
privates and corporals
do things up to snuff, so
he got us to explain to him
and our classmates what we understood
or thought we understood
what was going on,
so it was really very
effective the same way
all the way through.
So we had a special experience
because so many of our teachers
had come from Second World War
and without any preaching us
or any overt discussion of it
really they were conveying something
about the seriousness of
learning what you could
and taking advantage of it.
- And then what about Stanford,
any teachers stand out there?
- The very first day I met
my first professor ever
and he was Harold Johnston,
now retired from Berkeley
where he later became a very,
very distinguished scientist,
but this first day he was a
very shy assistant professor.
But he told us immediately,
this little group of six advisees
that gathered with him the
day before classes began,
something that opened my eyes immediately,
he said the university exists to preserve,
transmit, and create knowledge.
Well, I knew they had
libraries and all that,
I knew the transmission was
as in high school teaching,
I no idea about research,
so I think that I probably
heard of it first that day
and then he told us a little
about his own research
which was in the field
called chemical kinetics,
trying to unravel what governs
how rapidly chemical reactions occur.
Usually they're multi-step processes
and it's very tricky to figure out
what may really be going on
with the tools that were available then,
but it got me very
interested in a basic field
and later that was a key
part of my own research.
- Let's talk a little about doing science
before we get into the
work that you have done
and I'm hoping that you
can help us understand
what you see as the temperament,
the character required
to to do scientific work.
- I think it helps a
lot if you are A: Naive
and B: Have a high threshold
for frustration and confusion.
I like to tell my students
that the neophyte student
and the veteran researcher
are very much alike
in one important respect,
namely both are confused most of the time.
The difference is the neophyte
is usually often upset
about being confused, especially
if they're a bright student
gone through high school and
all and been patted on the head
all the time for breezing
through courses what not
and they find it's a
different thing in college,
especially when they start some research.
They naturally think oh,
there must be something wrong
with me or maybe the professor,
whereas the veteran
researcher is very happy
when they're confused because he realizes
unless you're confused, if
it's perfectly clear already
then you're not gonna learn anything new.
Furthermore, the researcher
knows that in science
you have a very special advantage
over essentially all
other human enterprises.
I like to emphasize this
because I think most people
don't really recognize it,
namely what you're trying
to find out in science,
call it truths or understanding,
waits patiently for you.
It doesn't change, contrast
that with a chess game.
You might make a great move, but whoops,
your opponent makes a better one,
so in business, politics,
sports, sadly war,
people often make a very
well-conceived sensible move
but whoops, it's a little
late or a little early
and turns out to be a fiasco or disaster
instead of a triumph.
In science you can get it
wrong over and over again.
It doesn't matter if
you find the right way,
the right perspective an idea eventually,
so I tell my students
that to be a scientist
is something like being a musician.
A musician really needs to love music,
devote a lot of effort into
mastering their instrument,
but in science you can play
99.9 % of the notes wrong,
get one right and be justly applauded.
- So it sounds like you're saying
that there is a patience here
that if one doesn't have it
in the beginning, one
develops it over time
because as you say nature is waiting
and it's just, to use
the language you used
in yesterday's lecture, it's
you just have to find the way
to get access to the right conversation
to hear what's going on.
- Yeah, I often add after
saying the kind of thing
I just said to you,
that you should realize
you probably will play
99.9% of the notes wrong,
so you need this immunity to frustration
that I mentioned already.
And you need to understand
that you do have
this advantage in science that
it's waiting there for you.
The Czech poet who wrote
a poem, not about science,
but it could apply to science,
he said the poet really
doesn't write the poem,
it's already there, it's
been there a long, long time,
he merely finds it.
(laughing)
- Now what about courage?
And I raise courage because
for truly outstanding insights
you really have to go out there
on a limb sometimes right?
So does your naivete compel
you to or help you do that?
And therefore you're not as
courageous as you look or what?
- Yes, I was going to
refer back to my remark
of how it helps to be naive at the start
because in a fundamental sense
it's naive to do science at all,
to think that you can really figure out
something fundamental
about how nature works,
but the motivation is very strong.
It grows from the sense of
wonder at finding ourselves
in this incredible universe.
So if you're deeply moved
by that it keeps you going
and I think it helps also to have a sense
especially fostered by
interacting with people
who you admire very much for
what they've done in science
and very often for their human qualities,
it helps very much that these
young mentors and colleagues
because then you know you're
part of this whole enterprise
and you're part may turn out
just to be something small,
but nonetheless it adds to whole effort
so this fellowship of striving
is a very strong reinforcement.
- And this is very much a cosmopolitan,
a global fellowship in the sciences.
- Science is very much
a social enterprise.
Often competition among
scientists is played up,
but that's very misleading
because science is intrinsically
very cooperative, very
democratic in that ideas
that turn out to have
merit are really found out
and ideas that aren't are too eventually
and it doesn't matter
where they come from.
I mean this is this centennial
of the miraculous year
of 1905 where this unknown
patent clerk sent in these papers
that changed perspective
of physics in ways
that are still echoing a century later--
- You're referring to Einstein, yeah.
- But he was publishing
papers without a PhD
all this from unknown
place, so it may not be
quite as easy sometimes
today with reviewing gauntlet
that authors often have to run
and the need to find funding
often if it's a specially
experimental project
that needs special
apparatus and all the rest,
so in the real world
there's kind of mundane
but difficult obstacles to deal with.
So that's why you need this
kind of evangelical fervor
to pursue an idea, naive
evangelical fervor if you like,
pursue an idea that may not be
already recognized by those.
You need some mavericks
and you have to have a
system of support in science
and a scientific community
that permits some mavericks
to roam around and they may
not solve some major problem,
but they may give a new
perspective which allows people
to get around, recognize and
get around some roadblocks
that have been in the way of the path
that consensus had seemed to endorse.
- Talk a little about
this creative movement.
We'll talk about your work in a minute,
but what is it about, I'm curious
because the way you were
talking about discovery
and the creative moment
where just in general terms
where you see something,
it sounded almost like
a religious experience, but it's not.
- No, no.
- Or is it?
- It has some kinship.
I think of our science
as really a kin to art
and other humanistic activities
because I have my students
write poems for example.
I tell them that writing a poem
is more like doing real science,
frontier science, than the
usual textbook examples,
which tell you just the
information you need
in a context that's carefully
set up so it's pretty clear
you're supposed to try to get the answer
in a certain way and so on.
Well, in the real world
is nothing like that.
Nobody knows the right answer
if you're doing research,
true research domain that's wide open,
nobody knows the right questions even
or necessarily the right approach.
So, I like to say science
is necessarily child's play.
Children are fantastic learners,
they learn with very little help
from adults in their native language.
Of course there's reason to think
there's some inbuilt propensity to this,
but even so it's quite
astonishing how quickly young kids
do it and one advantage
they have over adults
is they're not worried whether
they're getting it right.
They just play and they
sort of experiment.
I think they hear these
huge people make sounds
and see that they react to them
so they want to emulate
that and that's what happens
and that's something like what you do
in scientific research.
You you have to play in a
way and you have to guess
and you're often not, you
find your guess doesn't lead
to a sensible result so
you try something else.
That's the kind of thing it is.
People often think oh, well a scientist
has all these pens in the
pocket and are well organized
and know just what they're doing.
No, no, not at the frontier,
so the corresponds to the poem
is very close in that the
poem is a personal thing,
there's no question whether
it's right or wrong,
it's whether it illuminates
in an interesting way,
even some commonplace situation,
so it opens your eyes
to new possibilities.
That's exactly what we cherish in art
if we experience the
performance or painting
or sculpture that sort of makes us see
some aspect of the world or
human experience differently
ever after, it's the same
criteria that you judge
a scientific contribution by
if it changes the way you think
and what you do next.
- In your own work as
you emphasized yesterday
in your lecture, you were in a way
standing on the shoulders of
scientists who came before you
so in a way, let's talk now
a little about your work
and help us understand
how you know what you did
in layman's terms to merit a Nobel Prize
and how it actually reflected a lot
of what you've just described
namely working in a community,
but at the same time
being as you say somewhere
on the lunatic fringe
of a physical, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Talk a little about that.
- Yeah, well, I think its
characteristic in fact
of many, many episodes
or adventures in science
that I've witnessed in my
time and read about in history
because I love history and
it's certainly generally true
that as I mentioned before,
science is intrinsically cooperative.
Every scientist knows how much they owe
to their predecessors and
even to their contemporaries
even if nominally they
might look to be competitors
or whatever since you have
to announce to the world
whatever you find in science,
your nominal competitor
may actually help you more
than they help themselves
because what they find and
report may from your perspective
advance your development, the
problem more than their own.
Anyway, what happened in my case was,
as I mentioned earlier,
Harold Johnston, my mentor,
was doing a classic kind of research
on how fast chemical reactions go,
but that's all in the bulk,
that's all people could do then
and people just thought
it was not feasible at all
to carry out experiments
where you could study things
at the level, individual
collisions, if that detail
one would love to have
about what actually happens
in these collisions.
How much energy goes into
separation of products
or vibration of the new bonds
or tumbling rotational motion
and fundamentally then from
understanding the forces
that govern such things,
how the electronic structure
reactions and products determine
what's going to happen.
It's the most fundamental
thing in chemistry,
so it's difficult to get at
that in the conventional way
because as I always like to say
suppose you could only study
human psychology by flying
a blimp over a stadium
listening to the murmuring
and shouts of the crowd.
The chemist in more or less that condition
by having to work with
zillions of molecules
in the test tubes and on most
of what you'd like to know
in averaged down.
And the method we developed
was pretty obvious and naive.
Oh well, if you have a high vacuum,
so you pumped out molecules
that otherwise would be there
you can form two streams very
dilute streams of molecules
which are spaced far enough apart
that they don't interact with
each other in either stream
and they'll cross, a few
of them will collide.
If you have enough
sensitivity you can detect
the newly formed products as
they fly through the vacuum
to your detector, so
single collision chemistry.
And it turned out that
initially a simple class,
a special class of reactions
that people thought
was non representative and involving,
so called alkali reaction like a sodium
was reagents that included halogens
because sodium is willing
to give up an electron
to halogen containing marloxes very easily
so it's a rather facile,
more rapid reaction than most
so you could hope to get a bigger yield
and therefore even under
these severe conditions.
So that's dilute beams interacting,
maybe you could detect something.
And as I mentioned yesterday,
in our first experiments
our yield was equivalent to
monolai or molecules a month.
This is pretty pruny by chemical terms,
but because these properties,
these special molecules,
we could detect at that level
with not terribly elaborate apparatus.
And we knew we could do that
by virtue of previous work
of other people that didn't
quite get to the point
of doing this, so this is what happens
in every new generation.
I tell students sometimes you
may think from the textbooks
and from all you read and so on,
that gee, previous scientists had it easy,
they just get all these lovely results,
what's left for you to do?
And what you may not recognize
is that you have a legacy of new tools,
concepts as well as instruments and all
that open up new eyes
literally that you can use
to see things your predecessors could not
and to think of doing
probes nobody thinks of
until sort of the technical
feasibility of actually doing it
is somewhere on the horizon at least.
If it's too far over the horizon
people don't even imagine it,
so that's why early days people
said that's lunatic fringe
to think you can study
chemical reactions that way
and basically what we did was just show
that that's not the case.
And when it came to going into
a broader range of reactions
that was technically a lot harder
and people really thought
that was out of question,
but by then we developed
a lot of experience
with the easier ones and
especially with the genius
of Joo Hwan Lee as a
superb experimentalist,
we were able to go on and
do it and many other people
soon found they could do, sort
of like the four minute mile,
so long people thought you couldn't do it,
once it was done, very soon
other people were doing it too.
- So and as you recounted yesterday
that there's experimentation,
there's tinkering, there's
sort of building apparatus
that will make this possible.
But you're also looking back in time
because this came from
a line of experiments
done by a physicist I guess named Stern--
- He was a chemist by training--
- Oh chemist, okay--
- Yes, remember he got
his PhD in chemistry
for dissolving CO2 in various solids,
beginning you would hardly imagine
led ultimately to the work he did.
- And then, but then moving ahead
because there are analogies what you did,
but let me ask this question
and remember I'm not a scientist,
there are analogies with what you did
to what Townes had done in physics
to discover the labor in terms of the way
the apparatus was set
up to make discoveries.
- They had a kinship.
I mean if you think of it,
it's a really an evolutionary thing.
What Otto Stern did was ancestor
both to Townes' discovery
of the MASER and then the
LASER and to the work we did
and to much other work, so
all these kind of evolved.
what happens is things get combined
and out of the combination
new things grow,
that's kind of biology we're
talking about now right?
so this is the biology if you like
of intellectual development
of what is physical science.
I mean the ideas are terribly important
and they propagate and
combine and spawn progeny.
That's really what happens.
- And what is the implications
for a general audience
of the work that you did?
I mean I gather it it can help us
in understanding global
warming, is that a fair--
- Yes, there are lots of
practical applications,
so many in fact that it's
a little embarrassing
if you start listing them
because it sounds that
oh, you're taking credit
for everything under the sun
and the reason is simply
that it's so basic.
This is the way I try to explain it,
I say nature speaks to us in many tongues
and they're all alien,
alien not foreign, alien.
And what the research
scientist in the basic sense
is trying to do is decipher
one of nature's dialects
in some area, the vocabulary,
some of the grammar
to the extent you succeed, you
discover she's left messages
all the places we couldn't read before.
So in that sense you see basic research
is just trying to understand
is the most practical possible
because enables you to read the messages.
There plenty of historical
sawdust we can trace
where huge effort in human
and financial resources
were devoted with no result
and later you see the
reason why you couldn't read
the messages that were there all the time
because you didn't have the basic science
that made it possible to go ahead.
Often when the basic
science is there, zingo.
Take the development of the atom bomb.
That was very short time
after the discovery of fission
which was motivated
entirely by basic science,
nobody was looking for that.
Another example is often cited
is the discovery of X-rays.
If you tried to ask what
could you do for surgery
no one would have gone in a direction
that would have led to
discover X-rays, on and on.
The whole business of nanochemistry
you hear about so much work
and fascinating new materials,
all that came from playing
around with molecular beams
and discovering that gee, you
got a big peek at Carbon 60
when you expanded carbon vapor
through one of those supersonic nozzles
I mentioned yesterday.
What could that be?
And they played around and said gee,
it must have a structure
something like a soccer ball
that touched it all off, so you don't know
what's going to grow
from it, but you do know
that with basic research since
you're learning something
in nature's language,
there's really a whole literature there
that becomes accessible to you.
So that's the nature of the work we did
and it turns out even though we've studied
only a certain range of
reactions because we could do it
in this fundamental level
of single collisions
and therefore figure out what it meant
in terms of how the
electrons cover what happens,
which you'll be talking about today,
it's transferable to a
huge range of reactions.
I don't know, DNA anywhere,
if you have a certain bonding situation,
if you say oh yeah,
that's what's gonna happen
when they react, see what I mean?
So it turns out relevant to practically,
well, really all of
chemistry, that's the answer.
- You touch on a very interesting problem
because society and government
seem increasingly unable
to understand this connection
between basic research
and all the goodies that come out of it
whether for the economy,
for industry, and so on.
How do we get around that problem?
I know that one way that you like to do
is actually talk about
the history of science,
talk a little about that.
- Well, what comes to mind is
I've several times in
recent years been involved
in looking for a new director
for this nonprofit organization
or president for this society
and you read the books
about how to interview candidates,
what they tell you is you
ask questions that find out
what is relevant in their past performance
to the qualities you think
this person should have.
Don't ask them can you do this or that,
what you want them to
do, but ask questions
that find out whether they've
done something already
that illustrates their capacity
and their sort of instincts and so on.
Well, that's what we
do in science isn't it?
I mean we have a curiosity to understand
something fundamental that has emerged
probably out of a lot of other work,
they sort of grows and you know
I love this quote of Feynman
who said "science is
not about what we know,
it's about what we don't know."
And so really good science
is opening up your eyes
to more things you don't know,
so it defines important questions
to focus on and when you
address those of course
you ask what, that way you know already
can we bring to the surface
of this new challenge?
And usually it involves
putting things together
in a new combination, a different way
than people had in mind before.
- Now in one interview that I heard
that you had given you talked a lot about
Ben Franklin and what struck me
as I listened to your
account of his success
as a public figure and as a scientist
that we're not as successful these days
in identifying these achievements
of particular scientists
to essentially build a
legitimacy for science.
In that account of Franklin
I thought that that's what you were making
a very interesting insight about
namely that here was a
guy who had a public role,
was actually doing very basic science
and when we look back at him
we don't realize that
in a funny kind of way
we remember him as one
of the founding fathers.
- Yeah, it's very interesting.
He was a very curious man
about all kinds of things,
Self-educated, two years of school only.
He retired at age 42,
42, halfway through life
in order to concentrate
completely on these experiments
for electricity that had obsessed him,
as is the way he described it.
Although he's very practical
minded guy as the image,
the icon says, that's quite
true, but he had no idea
that it would lead to anything practical.
In fact, there's a
famous letter to a friend
in which he confesses
that he can see no future
for any value of practical
value of electricity
except to keep a vain man humble.
Because he was trying to figure out,
you have to realize up to
then electricity was a toy.
You rubbed glass with
fur, you got some sparks.
What touched it off was the discovery
of the so called light jar
we could store some electricity
and then people started
making electrical generators
that were really a way of
rubbing fur against glass
and generating more sparks,
so with that equipment
you could start exploring, and
he did this beautiful series
of experiments that
clarified what it was like.
Then he recognized gee,
lightning must be electrical.
Now at that time lightning was
thought to be supernatural,
so that had enormous impact
and it had the practical result
of lightning rods, which is
no minor thing in those days.
Well, that made his reputation enormous.
He was called a Newton of electricity.
In a way it was more shocking than Newton
if you don't mind a pun,
because people were familiar
with gravity and Kepler's
analysis of planetary motions
and all that before
Newton's fantastic theory
of what all happens.
Franklin didn't provide
mathematical theory,
that had to wait for Maxwell's equations
the next century and all, but
he had provided this insight
and all and it opens eyes so much
that he was recognized as
a very great scientist.
It had so much to do with why
he was successful in France
and getting the French to
donate the money and the troops
and made it possible for
this ragtag 13 colonies
to defeat the most
powerful military nation
the world had ever
known up till that time.
So respect for the nation's
scientific capabilities
especially when you are
the leading debtor nation
in the world as the
colonies certainly were then
and we're now in that situation ourselves.
- Except now we don't
recognize the science.
- You don't recognize the lesson,
well, we should recognize
since so many young people
from the rest of the world
come here to study science
in our universities that
the rest of the world
does admire our science,
but also the science
is not something that you can plant
and preserve just one place.
With the right encouragement
it takes root everywhere.
Stem cells are a good example.
If for political reasons we are hampered
as we are right now are,
or even prevented from pursuing
research in stem cells,
it's gonna go on, it's going
on brilliantly in South Korea
right now, they're the world's leader
in doing the most interesting research,
developing new ways to get stem cells.
- Somebody who thinks a lot about history
about the history of science
and science and history,
what is your analysis of
the sort of difficult period
we're going through in the dialogue
between science and society?
Is there a failure here?
Is it the politicians
manipulating the discourse
to get votes, is it religious
constituents who are concerned
about seeing the world in a different way,
or has science itself failed in some way
to help legitimate
itself in this dialogue?
- Well, I think the
fundamental problem is that we,
I mean everybody, scientists,
all the people you've named,
have allowed science to be perceived
as not part of our general culture,
but something that's just
separate for this subspecies
of geeks or nerds or whatever,
and if it would be recognized
that that is not actually so,
that science is a shared human
adventure, our whole species.
I could talk a lot about that,
but we need to break down
this notion of science is something
just for these very special people
and we hope we get some
benefits if we allow them
to play around in something
we don't understand
and so forth.
That's not in the long run
sustainable or healthy situation
for society, so what I think
is crucial is that we find ways
to integrate science in our
whole educational enterprise.
For example, the founding
fathers in the age of reason,
that's when our country
placed great value on science,
wonderful statements by
John Adams and so on,
not only Ben Franklin.
We've already seen how important
his scientific stature was.
The fact that our nation exists at all,
but Jefferson, he had read Principia,
the Principia of Newton
in the original Latin
and we have correspondence
between physicists of the day
who knew Jefferson was
very well read in Newton,
who would send what we'd call
a preprint to ask his opinion
because so often they were
referring to something
that Principia was a foundation
of so much development
at that time of ideas in
science, and we have letters
where Jefferson wrote back and said
well, you don't have this just right,
this is what Newton really was saying.
Imagine!
Okay?
And here's another story about Jefferson,
when he went to France
as successor to Franklin
as our ambassador there, he was
appalled by the French plows
which were so crude.
You know, his whole political philosophy
was based in the idea of free farmers
and a nation free farmers and all that,
so he sent himself, Jefferson did,
the problem of improving the plow,
particularly what's called a moldboard,
the thing that peels the soil back,
you know, has a very beautiful
shape, that's Jefferson!
He recognized that was a calculus
problem, he knew calculus,
he solved it, and then
he not only did that
he figured out how to
instruct the machinist
to approximate the calculated
solution that he got.
For a hundred years that
was the standard plow,
French gave him a gold medal.
He was however, philosophically opposed
to patenting anything, so
he didn't, and as you know
he died a pauper for other reasons.
Anyway, these stories ought to be part
of our whole education.
It's shared stories that make a society,
but we have blinders on.
When you study history
you don't talk about
the importance of Franklin's
stature as a scientist
in history, you don't talk
about Jefferson and his plow.
When you do calculus for that matter,
you don't have kids solve the plow problem
that Jefferson saw.
There's lots of ways we
can knit together science
and other courses.
Until a lot of science is
integrated into other courses
we won't begin to break down this notion
that it's something totally separate
instead of something that's pervasive
that naturally shows up all over.
I mean for example, if you
ever come across in history
how it was that the
Greeks beat the Persians
and the famous battleships,
it was because the Greeks
had sliding seats in rowing
which made them much more efficient
and much more maneuverable.
That was a scientific and
technological improvement.
Over and over you have
this through history,
but because history in our mind
is something about generals
and politicians, they ignore the things
that make really the much more
fundamental changes often.
Well, we can do better and we
have to do it I think in a way
that gets teachers and faculty together
to share these mini cultures
and find that they can hybridize
produce something new,
again a biological metaphor.
- It sounds like you're
saying that in a way
that the short term problem may
be press coverage of science
and of scientific discovery,
but the real basic issue here
the fundamental issue lies in the way
we educate future generations
so that they know science
but know how science fits into women kind
and mankind's story,
that's what you're saying?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And what do you see going
on in science education?
Are we meeting that
challenge that you're posing?
Is the curriculum at places
like Harvard and Berkeley
reflecting that need to integrate science
with the humane disciplines?
- I'm afraid I can't say
yes much as I would like to.
The compartmentalization
is a very powerful force
in large institutions as you know.
And there are a few people I know of,
the proverbial voices in the wilderness
except it's hardly a
wilderness it's the opposite
that speak in this
direction and I can quote
many from the past who have too,
but I think we're gonna
have to just keep at it
like the myth of Sisyphus
you push the rock up the hill
and the version I like is a Czech version
where as the rock rolls down
again as he knew it would be
he's whistling as it goes down the hill
knowing he has to push it up again.
If you think it's a truly worthy thing
you keep doing what you
can in that direction.
- I know that in some
of your voluntary work
you've been very active in programs
that identify budding scientists
and high schools and so on.
What are you seeing out
there in terms of the way
talent is emerging, is
it the way it always was?
And then the failure lies
with the educational system
or what?
Talk a little about that.
- Well, this is the most positive thing.
In fact, in my judgment at the moment
and it's something we
could build on far better
than we do, especially now
with this wonderful tool
the web, which of course can be misused
and is, can be just a garbage dump
instead of a cornucopia
as it also is fortunately
of powerful information and methods.
I don't think for example,
we're ever going to have
in the foreseeable future
as many qualified teachers
of science and math as we need.
However, if we realized
that the kids that wind up
going pretty high up in these fairs
that you mentioned, high
school science fairs,
The science talent search
is the most well known,
but it's just 40 finalists
in Washington each spring.
There's a lesser-known, but much bigger
international science and engineer fair
both of those incidentally
now are sponsored by Intel
as the prime sponsor, which
is a very sensible thing
given the nature of Intel as a company.
The International Science Engineers,
1,400 kids from 50 countries,
they meet in a different city every year
and they've all been winners
in regional, state, or local fairs.
Now you go talk to those kids,
they're very aware of these
science education problems
in the schools they came from.
They would love to be a resource
to interact with their own schools.
We could generate a great
network, which is kids.
Remember the story I
told about my experience
in high school with my teacher in algebra.
Well, these kids can do wonders
and there are instances
in college education,
my colleague Eric Misour at Harvard,
Alex Pines here at
Berkeley, have done a lot
with what's called peer instruction
where you pose questions
and the students argue out
and they vote and then they find out
whether we got the right idea.
Then they argue again to see
if they can understand why,
so the key thing is getting
students in the first place
to take ownership instead
of allowing it to seem
to belong to some higher authorities,
the previous generation or whatever,
and then they'll get the
wider community therefore
to take ownership too.
What I would love to see since we're here
before our TV cameras,
is every week on the news
and every network, one
or two minutes segment
allowing one of these
kids from a science fair
to describe their project.
They're usually excellent at it
because in working their way
through a series of fairs
they've had to describe their
project to whoever comes,
sometimes little kids,
sometimes even scientists
and they adjust
accordingly and they learn.
They're the best ambassadors for science
because the attitude
that I mentioned before,
that society feels
science is too rarefied,
they won't understand and all that
and that's been implicated in school
unfortunately for most
people, puts them off.
If you have a scientist
speaking, even though sometimes
we have marvelous programs, NOVA and all,
they're not watched generally as widely
as they really deserve to be,
but everybody then would see kids,
everybody's interested in a
kid just because they're a kid
but also then they
discover they're very good
at explaining their science and teachers,
other kids, parents, they'd watch,
I think it would be a regular thing.
I think that would change very much
the whole society's
attitude and as you know TV
the way it works there's plenty
of little one or two minute
gaps they have to fill, we know
what they fill it with now,
this could be done.
- It sounds to me like we
have a real role model problem
in the sciences.
Our current president is not Jefferson,
we don't have Franklins
in the hall of Congress
and so the it sounds like you're saying
that in fact we may wind up having to turn
to the excitement of younger people,
the newer generation actually
doing science actually
to inspire a broader sense
of what science can do.
- I think it would be the
best way to go in fact.
Science is a very useful
thing even if it's done
by very senior people occasionally.
It's intrinsically useful I
said earlier, it's child's play.
Well, of course, you don't
say that to funding agencies,
but in a serious way it has to be
if you're talking about basic science
that has a chance to learn
some of nature's language
and that's the most
fundamental and as I argue
the most practical kind we can do.
And of course there's a whole range
I wouldn't belittle science
in the service of a short term
technological aim, that's
making use of what we've learned
already of nature's language
and often in a very
enterprising imaginative way,
but if we fail to recognize
that we've got to have people
who are so inclined, scientists,
to have this burning urge
to probe deeper in a fundamental way,
we are losing out on the most
important long-term aspect
which is to learn more
from nature's language,
explore more of that
ignorance that opens up
as we learn more as Feynman emphasized.
- How would you advise students
who want to go into science
to prepare for the future?
- Well, I think they
should explore widely,
not just science and math,
but literature, history,
they could should make themselves
person who has wide eyes
'cause often what you wind up doing
in all kinds of thought,
but I think especially
pronounced in science
is metaphorical kind of
comparisons and analogies
and often the thing that
you think of in science
isn't some narrow technical
thing that depended on
having taking X number
of courses or something
to get you this point.
No, it's some down to Earth
metaphor with something done
that people wouldn't ordinarily think of
as related to science at all.
It may be related to art
or music or whatever.
I mean a lot of what you do
in say chemical synthesis
where you have these simple
elements, chemical bonds,
often you're specially
interested in biological things
then the main atom,
their carbon, hydrogen,
nitrogen, oxygen, the big
four, maybe a few others
here and there, so the
elements are simple.
Well elements of the Beethoven
composition are pretty simple
you just have a few notes
intervals and what not,
but it's matter how you assemble them,
so it's the same thing.
I like to say science is
not really a technical thing
as much as an architectural thing.
An architect has to understand
quite a few technical things,
but that's not the
essence of architecture.
Architecture itself is more
than that, it's a broad thing
that has to recognize
the aim of the project
and the fact that how are people
going to experience this space.
How's it gonna serve the
functions, the activities?
So it has to be very broad and
so a lot of the best science
is architectural in character.
You don't necessarily invent the materials
or the building construction,
but you put them together
in a way that opens people's
eyes to new possibilities
that they didn't see before.
Just the thing we admire when we say wow,
that's really good architecture,
that's the character
that's so important to recognize I think.
- Standing back and seeing the whole.
- Yeah, so that's why I say an
education that's very broad.
For example, Einstein who was of course
the most convenient icon,
especially this year,
he had a very broad cultural education.
His mother was a fine
pianist, so he learned music.
He fell in love with Mozart about age 13,
he'd studied the violin since six,
and he said that he never really
began learning to play well
until I fell in love with Mozart.
He said love is a much
better teacher than duty.
It certainly was for him,
not only in the violin,
but elsewhere, and
that's we have to foster.
You see every little kid is a scientist,
they're just so damn
curious, they inevitably are
and too much of our social
and educational system
tends to quench this because
oh, the important thing
is to get the right answer.
Well, that's not the important thing
when you're doing science
because the people don't
know the right answer,
so you're asking instead am I
thinking in an interesting way
and I come up and approach,
so that puts a great premium
on individual imagination,
just what counts in a poem.
Whereas the image of science
is nothing like that.
The student gets the
impression that there's no room
for individual scope because you learn
how to do everything in the right way
well that means only one way.
There's not only one way.
Even in mathematics, the
crucial kind of invention
comes from people who do it
a different way than others.
- Well on that note of hope actually
for what we will be able
to achieve in the future
I wanna thank you very
much Professor Herschbach
for coming back to
Berkeley and taking time
to be on our program, thank you.
- That's been my pleasure.
- Thank you, and thank you
very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(upbeat instrumental music)